それからブッダが語る教育の順番
はい あれで終わった 慣れることはこれ別な世界に入ります
それで正しい教育はどんなものかと
お釈迦様は教えているんです
これがプログレッシブララーニングということで
これは結構覚えた方がいいんです
しかし 今日教える教える教育方法は
お釈迦様が自分の教えを勉強してどう成功するのかということを念頭に入れて
まあ宗教家が宗教家に語っているものなんです
だから 皆様の中学校の教育システムとか何とかというレベルじゃないんです
だからちょっと大人の世界なんです
1番目 サマンネーサティということをするんです
サマンネーサティ サマンネーサティということを比較する
調べる 探す チェックするという意味なんですね
まずデータ集めてチェックするんです
勉強する前に いきなりどこかの学校に入学するんじゃないんです
とことん調べる 大人の世界で
例えば大学院生ぐらいになってくると
世界でどんな大学に入るのかと思っちゃうと
名前では入れませんよ
オックスフォードは有名だからとか
コロンビアユニバーシティ有名だからとかは入りません
カリフォルニア大学に入ろうとか
それはないし その代わりにもう大人だからね
私に勉強してくれる教授はどこにいるのかと
私の研究分野に対して指導できる人間がどこにいるのかと
その人間がコロンビアユニバーシティいるんだったら
そちらに入る もし南アフリカの大学にいるんだったら
その大学の院生になる
名前で入るのはもうバカしか入りませんよ
あの大学は有名だからとか
僕は認めません 自分をやりたいことはそちらで教えてくれるのかと
それがもう大事なことで
そこから仏教始まるんですよ
京大だから東大だからっていうことは
全く仏教はもう無視するんです
あるいは自分に習い 学びたい
学びたいものがもう大学でやってないんだと
他のどこかで誰かやってるんだったら
そちらに行くしかないんです
ですから 学問始まる前にこれ調べるんですよ
それ 誰から教えてもらうかは探すのです
その人に知識があるか
道徳 道徳があるかなど
その人を信頼する それからその人を信頼する
それでお釈迦様は自分のことを言うんですよ
まず君たちは私を調べなさい
私は調べなさい 心綺麗か
綺麗でないか 私は言っていることは事実かそうでないか
私の人格はどうでしょうかと
曖昧でしょうかと ぎっしり調べなさいよ
まず話は後へと そういう順番
仏教は まだお釈迦様はまた調べ方まで教えるんです
調べるっていったっても
頭の中何があるかわからないでしょう
人間の だから人間に見えるのは行動と言葉だよと
だからまず私の行動はどうでしょうかと
怪しいことでもしているのかと
表でどんな生き方をしているのかと
裏でどんな生き方をしているのかと
行動を調べなさい それから言葉調べなさいよと
表で喋る時 どんな言葉ですか？裏で一人でいる時
どんな言葉を使っているのかと
あるいは人を煽てて喋るのかと
あるいは人をけなして軽視でバカにして喋るのかと
そうやって言葉で調べなさいと
その時ももう悟りをチェックするんだからね
こういう言葉が怒りがある人に
欲がある人に 無知の人に言えるか言えないかとチェックしなさいと
こういう行動 こういう生き方は貪瞋痴がある人にもできるのか
あるいは貪瞋痴がないんだからこそ
この方こういう生き方をしているのかと
まず調べる それから次のステップは
この人はこんなまとめな立派な人格で演じているのは
あまり日に浅いか長いかで調べなさい
なぜかで 我々も 1 日だけ修行するとかね
1 日だけいい人間になるということはありますよ
タバコをやめたと  1日だけとかね
まあ 1日ぐらいだったら誰にでもいい人間になれますよ
私は酒やめますって言ったら 1日だけだったらと
それっていうのはできますから
良い人間でいるといる日にちは浅いか長いかと調べてくださいと
そういう風にブッダは先生にするならば
ブッダの学校に入るならば
まず調べるということはする
調べて終わったら信頼をするんですよ
あ この学校はよろしいと
それはサッダー信と言うんですね
サッダージャーとウパサンカマで
これで信頼をしたところで
そちらに入るんです 入学するんです
この場合はブッダの学校ですね
ブッダに一応入学入ってもらう
入る  3番目 ウパサンカントパイルパーサティ
入ってからまあちょっと付き合ってみる
一緒に生活してみたりとか
いろいろ付き合ってみる
4番目パイルパーさんとソウタンオーダーハティ
まあ付き合い付き合うと話を聞きたくなるんですよ
それで耳を傾け 傾けたくなる
だから一緒にいるとお釈迦様も話すでしょうし
どんどんなんとなく聞きたくなるんですよ
だから 嫌で嫌で勉強するんじゃないんですよ
自動的に面白い話です
素晴らしい話ですとかね
で 聞きたくなる 聞きたくなったら聞くんですよ
傾けて真理を聞く おいて相当ダンマンスナーティ
だから勉強しろ しろではないんです
仏教の順番は 一旦学校に入って
もう雰囲気にも慣れちゃって
先生たちのこともよく知って
いろいろやっぱり聞きたくなるんですね
勉強したくなるんですよ
したくなったところで
真面目に説法を聞いて勉強する
スッタダンマンダーレティ
それで勉強したものはまず覚える
仏教の場合は先に覚えるんですよ
なぜかというと 内容は難しい
いきなり 1発で理解できない
だから慣れることは先に来るんですね
この順番でスッタダンマンダーレティ
7番目ダターナンダンマーナンアッタンウパパリッカティ
それから覚えた真理 覚えたお釈迦様の教えの意味を観察するんです
あ こういう意味だ これはこういう意味だ
これはこういう意味だとかね
なんでこれでこうなるんでしょうかとかね
それから理解するんですよ
だから 覚えることと理解することはセットでなってくるんです
8番目アッタンウパパリッカトダンマーニッジャーナンカマンティ
それでどんどん意味を理解して理解していくと納得するんですよ
なるほど よくわかりました
と 生きることはドッカで苦しい意味であると
お釈迦様は教えたことを覚えておいたんだけど
わからなかったと でも
よくよくよくよく観察してみたところでわかりました
さすが生きることは苦しみであると理解するんですよ
納得するんですよ これはダンマニッジャーナって言うんですよ
ダンマニッジャーナ カンティア
サティチャンドージャーエティ
これでもうわかった ブッダの教えは真理だと
わかっただけで足らん
それからまた慣れる世界に入るんです
次にダンマニッジャーナ
カンティア サティチャンドージャーエティ
理解したところで納得いったところで
意欲が出てくるんですよ
やる気が まあ悟りのこともわかったし
解脱しなくちゃいけないということもわかったし
貪瞋痴で苦しんでいることもわかったし
輪廻転生は危ないともわかったし
結構わかってます 生きることは苦しみであるともわかったし
そうすると意欲が出てきます
やっぱりやらなくちゃと自動的に
チャンダジャートウッサーハティ
意欲が出てきたら それで頑張ってみる
実行 実践してみる 挑戦してみる
精進する 次にウッサーヒットはトゥレエティ
精進しながら比較するんですよ
それは現代我々 あまり瞑想する人々にはやらせないんです
で やるなよと禁止させておいたんです
理由は 何でしょうかね
経典にもあるのに 比較すること
これはね 頭が悪いからですよ
これは仏教の修行に励むのは
もうとことん仏教を理解したプロなんですよ
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想の意味
働き やり方を理解するために
学ぶために もう最低何年もかかりますよ
簡単ではないんです 瞑想を勉強する前に
この真理を別々に勉強しなくちゃいけないんですよ
五蘊って何なのか 煩悩って何なのか
なんでなんで どうどうなるのかとかね
そこであらゆるリストがあって
全部覚えなくちゃいけない
それ全部できたところで
ヴィパッサナーって何なのかを理解しておくんです
それにももう 2  3年は軽々とかかる
それからどちらにしたっても
先生と付き合わなくちゃいけない
仏教の世界で 一緒に生活して気に入って波長が合ったならば教えているんであって
でないとあまり喋れません
だから先生には説法せざるを得ないような環境
弟子に対して まあ愛情というか
心配の念が生まれるようにしなくちゃいけないんですよ
これは厳しい そういうところ
なぜならば 仏教が人格向上の教えだからね
これ 現代ヨーロッパのやり方で
それはカットしたったら
もうすべてカットしたことになるんです
だから人格向上の世界だから
先生が心配するかしないかということはとても大事なこと
先生が生徒のことを心配するならば
もう OK で それが先生は大人だから
もう心配する一方的に
あまり意味がない 生徒がそれなりに努力していないと
心配したくない気が荒い先生であろうとも
もう黙っていられない状態に追い込まないと
それで瞑想は一人でするんですよ
だってプロでしょうに
で 一人で瞑想して 自分がいろんな智慧が開発
発達していくんですよ
発達したところで 今まで習った仏教を理解した学問があります
なるほど お釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
こういうことだ 今私は自分で知ってるんだと
しかし お釈迦様は悟りはまだまだ程遠いだと
でわかったのはこんなもんやと
それが比較することなんです
まあゴールはまあまだ程遠いんだけど
あ ここまでは行きましたと
で また修行してやってみれば
あ まあここまでは行ってるんだと
なぜかというと 修行中はわからない
何が起きているのかと
瞑想終わってからどうなったんでしょうかね
今日はと  こういう声 それってどういう意味でしょうか
なるほど お釈迦様がおっしゃったのはあれが悪いことやと
そういうことで比較するんです
比較して トゥレイトアパダハティ
だから今までここまで達したと
では また頑張るぞと 反省するような感じなんですよ
はい では今度はこういうこと失敗したんだから
それはしないで こういう風にまたさらに頑張るぞと
で さらに頑張るんですね
比較しては努力する そのやり方で
十三パヒタット様のカーエーナチェーバパラマンサッチャンサッチカル
それで自分 努力修行する人は
自分で最高たる真理を体験する
体験するんですよ 涅槃を悟りを
最高たる真理を比較して進む
比較して進む まあ道路の場合は看板見ながら
道路の目印を見ながら先へ先へ行く
それで自分の目的に達する
で 自分で経験する それも慣れることなんで
もう身についちゃったってことなんです
それで終わらない 知恵によっても鋭くする
自分の知恵でも これこそこれ以上何もないと知るんです
それで学問は終わっちゃうんです
十三ぐらいのステージがあるんです
仏教の真理を知る知る
この教育方法 普遍的にも正しいと思います
これはある宗教家のいい話っていうわけじゃなくて
まあ現代教育でも そのやり方でやれば
もう行きますよ まず大人の世界で人を言うことは
何でもかんでも鵜呑みにするんじゃなくて
勉強する前に本当に資格あるのか
自分勉強したいものがその人に教える能力があるのか
その先生は金ばっかり狙っているのかどうかね
そういうところをまず調べるんですよ
それしないんだから 後で失敗して失敗して泣いたりする
習うこともラーニングですね
慣れることもトレーニングですね
両方が入ってます それでお釈迦様のあの十三リストに両方は見事に入ってるんです
一から八まで学ぶことです
九から十三まで実践慣れることです
最後に理解することも
身につくことも一つになるのです
それで完成したっていうことは
習うことも慣れることも一緒になって一つの位置に達するんです
人格は完成するんです
で ジムニカへのこのこのページですね
チャンキースッタっていう経典にあるんです
かなり教育方法みたいなものをある宗教家に教えたところ
仏教の人じゃない相手は
はぁ そろそろ疲れてきました
じゃあ十分後に  よし